going to bring you these live pictures
from central london there's greta
thundberg there who is
joining climate protesters
in london ahead of that cop 26
summit in glasgow now
we understand the teenage climate
activist is joining a march
through london today in protest at the
continued use of fossil fuels greta
tunberg there joining climate protesters
in central london now this demonstration
i should say is just one of
many that is happening in financial
centers around the world uh it looks
quite boisterous down there lots of
people trying to get
a picture of the teenager who has become
so well known around the world now when
it comes to this issue of climate change
speaking very eloquently and very
publicly on many an occasion and no
doubt we will see her in glasgow as well
but protesters they're joining her
demanding the global financial system in
which london plays a major role stops
putting money
into the use of fossil fuels let's just
see if anyone is speaking can we hear
anything down there
just a lot of shouting at the moment by
the looks of things
but activists we understand are going to
be protesting
outside
big banks down there
in central london today and and marching
through at the center of the city in
protest of the use of fossil fuels just
days before the cop 26 summit
in glasgow
it could be one of the largest climate
finance protests in history today
and it's taking place in other financial
centers as well including new york
san francisco san francisco and nairobi
but those pictures
in central london
protesters joined by swedish
teenager and climate activist greta
thuneberg
in central london protesting against
fossil fuels just days from cop 26.
[Music]